let's go to congressman august fluger
republican of texas
um the congressman that said it would be
advisable for the vice president
to stop at that border has been urging
the president to do his vote himself
uh joins us right now congressman we
don't know exactly
what the vice president's plans might
end up being she might surprise folks
and get to the border if she did
uh what do you think she should pay
attention to
well neil the administration president
biden vice president harris have
abdicated their responsibilities
to keep americans safe they have
abdicated their duties that uh
just the clip we just heard this is a
federal issue
the state of texas had to declare
emergencies
in 34 counties now think about that
we're spending millions
of dollars here in the state of texas to
keep ourselves safe meanwhile the
administration wants to send 300 million
dollars to northern triangle country i
think we need to focus right now
on what our border patrol agents need
now what's changed in this
administration is a lot of these cases
for those of you know who are you know
converging at the border
they they used to be adjudicated uh
under donald trump
on the mexican side of the border now on
the u.s side of the border uh
that's something you want to see change
but right now there are no
signs that it will be if it continues
like this then what
well if we're going to address the root
cause which is what the vice president
is saying
then we do need to adjudicate those in
mexico and before
the crisis and the surge reaches our
borders and that's what we've been
calling for all along
is to have remaining mexico policy
reinstated to have those agreements
with honduras el salvador guatemala
reinstated
just like president trump did he knew
what the source the problem was he was
working with those governments and
making sure
that the surge didn't happen and the
rhetoric is also something
that the the president cannot say with
either unsaid or policy that our borders
are open that's what's being
communicated to the rest of the world
right now
you know democrats have counted as you
know congress has been that these waves
of
you know incursions at the border
happened under republican and democratic
presidents alike that they happened
uh under donald trump on two different
occasions over two different years in
the span of his four-year term
and that you can't blame it on
administration per se
what do you say well sure i mean this
has been an issue that we've been
working to correct working to prevent
and finding solutions for
i think the key difference right now is
we've got four known terrorists that
have entered this country
this year we've got more fentanyl into
the state of texas
than we know what to do with in fact
that fentanyl could kill 21.5 million
people
in this in its total amount
so what we're doing right now is we've
completely reversed course on policies
that we're working to stem the flow
curb the tide and make sure that we
corrected the crisis that's occurring
you know while i have you and if you
don't mind my switching subject sir
we have this push for a global minimum
tax that
janet yellow the treasury secretary has
signed on to along with her six
counterparts
from some of the richest countries on
the planet and they include england and
france italy
and a few others i'm just wondering what
you make of that because it's been used
as a negotiating
tool to get republicans on board with an
infrastructure package
where corporate taxes won't be hiked
as the president had earlier planned but
this floor this 50 percent
global corporate tax would be would be
in place
what do you think of that well anytime
we're raising taxes on american people
i believe that we're doing the wrong
thing in 2017 the tax reform lowered
taxes to
record lows in 2019 we came into the
federal treasury with more
tax revenue in the history of this
country so now we're going to go into a
summit
uh with a position of weakness we're
asking the president to go with a
position of strength and meanwhile he's
just giving our industries
away he's giving our instruments a power
away so obviously this is very
concerning
for what the administration is doing we
don't support higher taxes in any way
shape or form
so if you got rid of the the the fear of
a 28
tax and you had a 15 corporate tax a
global tax you would not be for
that well i think we need to look at the
details and see how it
the cumulative effect of what it does to
our country
how that affects you know not just the
corporate rate but how does that trickle
down and affect the rest of the american
working-class people
got it all right congressman thank you
for coming in always good seeing you
august fluger the republican texas
congressman